- ALICE, FEEL BETTER.
TAKE IT SLEAZY.
- [coughs]
- THAT'S THE THING I'M SAYING
NOW--TAKE IT SLEAZY.
- I LIKE IT, YEAH.
- AS YOUR NEWLY APPOINTED
LEADER, OUR FIRST ORDER--
WAIT GUYS, DON'T LEAVE YET.
NO. WAIT, WE HAVEN'T FIGURED
OUT THE PAJAMA THING.
WAYMOND, YOU STAY RIGHT THERE.
GET THAT--NO.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
- THAT'S A HAT.
- HEY, GUYS, DO YOU MIND
GETTING BACK TO YOUR DESK
AND MAKE IT
A SUCCESSFUL WORK DAY?
- OOH!
- ONE MORE TOSS AND THAT'S IT.
OKAY, MAYBE NOT A BEER,
MAYBE PAPER WORK.
HEY, JET, OH.
UH, SO I WAS THINKING MAYBE WE
SHOULD DO THE GROUP PHOTO SOON.
- SUCK MY [bleep].
BE GONE.
- HEY, BLAKE, BE HONEST.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT ME
THAT NO ONE RESPECTS?
IS IT MY HAIR?
YEAH. I'M THINKING ABOUT
GETTING A NEW HAIRCUT,
CHANGING STUFF UP.
MAYBE GETTING LIKE AN...
ARNIE SCHWARZENEGGER,
JINGLE ALL THE WAY
TYPE OF HAIRCUT?
YOU KNOW, SHORT,
TALL AND STIFF.
KIND OF LIKE HOW I LIKE MY MEN.
[laughs]